Warner Brothers dropped a new trailer
for Suicide Squad and DC all-access is
here to sort through the comic book
history of Task Force X the trailer
opens inside the prison the Suicide
Squad calls home with convicts coping
with life behind bars and their own
unique ways like Harley Quinn enjoying a
cup of tea and a steamy romance novel
Harley is one of DC's most beloved
villains frequently paired with their
main squeeze mr. J aka the Joker
1994 is classic graphic novel Mad Love
by Paul Dini and Bruce Timm is one of
her greatest stories in the comics
members of the squad are recruited from
Belle Reve Penitentiary which is
anything but the beautiful dream it's
French name implies I want a simple a
task force of the most dangerous people
on the planet they're bad guys worst of
the worst
Viola Davis plays Amanda Waller the
mastermind behind Task Force X who first
appeared in legends number one in 1986
and later helped formed the Justice
League of America to learn about Wohlers
tragic backstory go check out 1987
Secret Origins number 14
here's Will Smith is Floyd Lawton aka
Deadshot who is such a beast
that it takes a dozen prison guards to
restrain him and here we see Diablo
living what must be a nightmare for
someone who has the ability to
manipulate fire was this cheerleading
tryouts that angry guy is Captain
Boomerang a flash rogue who debuted in
1960 as you might guess he hates being
on the Suicide Squad and doesn't get
along with his teammates in the comics
one of whom ranks best stories is 2004's
identity crisis where he tries to
reconnect with a son that he never knew
he had and he kills Robins dad spoilers
fry daddy cries good shot guy shoots
buffoon this is rick flagg boning up on
the squad's background info
curiously flanked by cara delevingne
outside of her enchantress persona Flagg
is sort of a field commander for Task
Force X and he notably starred in a 2007
miniseries called Suicide Squad raised
the flag that actually featured the
formation of a new Suicide Squad he's a
crack house he eats people Killer Croc
removes his hood to expose a scaly scalp
that was the result of a genetic atavism
in the comics a traditional Batman
villain who first appeared in 1983 croc
is one of the Dark Knight's most
physically intimidating and brutal
enemies croc appeared in the classic
Batman hush with more of a monstrous and
dinosaur image than his usual reptilian
self burns people you're possessed by a
witch
here's Cara Delevingne and her smoky
enchantress getup and the comics the
which manifests in the character June
moon whenever she says the word
enchantress you can catch some of her
comic book adventures in shadow pack vol
1 in which she joins a team of mystical
heroes to stop an evil group called the
pentacle and there's some detective
chimp in there too she's just crazy that
I should kill everyone and escape sorry
the voices slipknot looks understandably
skeptical of Harley Quinn as she jokes
about schizophrenia an assassin who
debuted in fury of firestorm number 28
in 1984 Slipknot is a familiar firestorm
foe who could teach even the best Eagle
Scout a thing or two about ropes this is
the deal very bad our first group shot
shows most of the team together on a
rubble line city street there have been
several incarnations of the Suicide
Squad over the years but the version
comprised the villains was introduced in
legends number three in 1987 something
that gets killed so save the world
Deadshot smash debuted in 1977 s
Detective Comics number 474 and will
make a great Halloween costume in 2016
so get going cosplayers I can't wait to
show you my toy it's Jared Leto as the
Joker the Joker is the most iconic comic
book villain ever and has been
reimagined by many different artists and
writers in his 76 year history but it
was the landmark graphic novel The
Killing Joke that cemented the vicious
modern identity of the Clown Prince of
Crime
hold on back that up a few frames this
might look like just another guy with a
gun but take a closer look at his sleeve
and you'll see mr. frost this is Johnny
Frost a henchman whose first appearance
in DC continuity was in the 2008 graphic
novel Joker no you're not seeing things
skulls seem to be evaporating off of
katana sword known as the soultaker
sword katanas blade steals the soul of
everyone it kills katanas best known as
a member of a team formed by Batman
called The Outsiders and she starred in
a solo series in 2013 that focused on
her search for a husband's killer
I could watch Will Smith assemble a
firearm to the beat of Bohemian Rhapsody
all day Deadshot is an expert marksman
in the comics and a core member of Task
Force X check out the seminal 1988
miniseries Deadshot beginnings to follow
Floyd Lawton on a bloodthirsty rampage
as he searches for his kidnapped son
boomerangs got the red idea let's all
crack open a cold beverage enjoy this
killer montage
Siri how do you grow muttonchops
pause here we see Joker lifting Harley
out of a pool of bubbling green liquid
and we can't help but think of Harley's
new 52 origin story from Suicide Squad
number 7 where Harleen Quinzel falls
into a vat of acid and emerges as the
clown princess of crime this is exactly
the kind of comics come to life action
we're so excited for seriously the
hell's wrong with you people I know
right for bad guys this is what we do
that's our breakdown of the new Suicide
Squad trailer be sure to click subscribe
and also check out Suicide Squad Most
Wanted Deadshot katana number 1 which is
available in stores right now today